hun
so Doug I want to ask you a little bit
about the themes in Siberia I'm
particularly fascinated and I've been
fascinated with this term cyber Daleks
which connects the idea of cybernetic
systems and computers and high
technology with psychedelic substances
expanding your mind there's a lot of
people out there that think that the
computer revolution is the
literalization of the psychedelic dream
of mind expansion and at the confluence
of the counterculture in the computer
culture in the early 60s like in a sense
sparked this world where it was like
these computers can't extend our minds
computers are the new LSD and so on and
so forth you know this world very well
do you want to just riff a little bit on
your thoughts on that well I don't know
for me it was kind of a surprise you
know I went I went to Princeton in the
early 80s when there weren't many they
weren't that many interesting people
there to use the word interesting there
certainly weren't many psychedelic
countercultural ii theater people there
and after I graduated I found that the
you know the other nine of the other 12
psychedelic Princeton people had all
ended up moving to California to work in
the high tech industry and that seemed
really weird to me because when I grew
up people who used computers were the
kids who kind of cut right angles in the
corridors of the high school and stuff
so I wanted to find out why people who
were for the most part more stoned than
I was you know the true dead had people
would go out there so I went out and you
know spent time with these people who
were you know working at Intel during
the day and going home scraping the buds
off peyote cactuses at night and while
trying to figure out why why were these
people attracted to it and then why were
these people the ones being hired to do
it you know and what I figured out in
the early
was that people who had hallucinatory
experience were really the only people
who weren't afraid to build these
platforms to build this reality these
were people who were accustomed to
imagining something that then appeared
right right so these are people who then
who had to go and do well I mean right
our job right off the bat I mean it
makes me think of this idea you know you
have all these companies that are
talking about creativity and
out-of-the-box thinking and we got to
get our employees to think differently
and don't look at what is but think of
what could be you know Steven Johnson in
his book where good ideas come from
talks about the adjacent pasta and he
says the adjacent possible is a shadow
future it's this thing it's not quite
there and it hovers over the president
it's I'll tell you that but though how
do you get the problem here though is it
that the deliberate in discipline
psychedelics users bring back what
they've learned back to Terra Firma
absolutely implement it in real life in
a real way yeah and there's there's a
kind of an implicit morality in that and
the the kinds of people who were doing
computers then were the kinds of people
who shared a kind of a common sense of
values about people and weirdness and
paradox and the arts and all that and
when I look at the people who are
programming our reality today I see kids
graduating from Stanford going to work
for Goldman Sachs to build algorithms
that are that work on the stock market
to outsmart human traders know so I
don't feel that that value system is
implicit anymore that this that the the
adjacent possible is no longer
necessarily connected to the real but is
an alternative reality let's build in
this platform you know and it harkens
back to stuff McLuhan was talking about
back in his dissertation when he wrote
about the Trivium that there were you
know these kind of two sexes and sort of
throughout history the grammarians who
were very concerned with sort of what is
and the dialect
additions the the constructivists who
were sort of out there on you know well
what can we do what can we construct
what else can we can and the
constructivist it was it was very
consonant with industrialization and the
renaissance and progress and where are
we going to go where we're going to take
this thing but you know that eyes on the
prize mentality is kind of an
abstraction when it's not
counterbalanced by being present being
present right by the real yeah and i
understand everything that you're
referring to here and so it's almost
sounds like what you're saying is that
that dream that existed maybe when you
wrote Siberia or the ideas that John
Markoff explores and what the Dormouse
says when he says that this 1960s moment
this counterculture these computers this
dream that was conceived and potentially
to be literalized now you're saying that
the value system that exists today is
not the same so instead of people
creating an app to transform the world
they want to create some little app that
they can like put on this wall right oh
yeah or even and you know in the best
case it's the it's the quest to make you
know second life you know second life
rather than this life you know where we
are alive yeah you know and and you know
and you know we talk a lot about the
singularity I get worried you know the
singularity to me seems to be kind of a
self-loathing kind of anti human zombie
apocalypse fantasy yeah well you know
where you know the the story they tell
is that you know the the the history of
evolution is information itself striving
towards greater states of complexity yes
human beings are really good and culture
is really good your or in there after
the last few thousand years but now
computers are even better at doing that
right people are only going to be
necessary insofar as we can help
computers manifest the next stage of
evolution and to argue as I do that no
humans matter we've got it is is is
hubris who says humans matter and I say
humans matter because I'm on team human
well it's interesting good when when
Kurzweil talks about the singularity and
he addresses the criticism where people
say oh the AIS are going to take over
and displace us he says you keep truck
talking about the AI as if it's them
but that's really gonna be us you know I
mean he echoes some of the ideas of
David Chalmers and Andy claw
who says we need to get over our skin
bag bias and that these technologies if
you zoom out and you look at it from the
outside these technologies are actually
a part of us
they are our second skin just like the
spider's web as a part of the spider our
smartphones our technology our computers
are like a scaffolding of mind I mean
when you look at the Mars rover on Mars
that's the human mind is crawling Mars
yeah but the Hubble Space Telescope
gives us allows us to mainline the whole
of time through our optic nerve so it's
not I don't think that we're being
replaced as much as we as far as being
augmented but this is my interpretation
I mean we're yeah I mean it depends if
you're if you're part of the Campton
wants to upload human consciousness to a
silicon ship and watch it go then then
then I think that then you've got no
problem with skinbag bias I'll tell you
that much
but I think there's a danger there that
that you know the the problem with
constructivism while it's it's great to
plan is it's very hard to keep you to
remember that we have to keep testing it
against reality you know what might be
has to continually be tested against
what is you know when it goes all the
way back to the other you mentioned the
first meeting they mentioned of text
once we could write things down once we
could write things down we got
time-travel right we could write about
you know what happened in the past we
got history and we got the future and
then we got them
you know messianism and Moshiach and all
that and Moshiach in the future and
where we're going in tikkun olam that's
all beautiful as long as it's constantly
tested against well but I think that
language allowed us to dream because by
conceiving of what might be is sort of
it was the catalyst for human
imagination and imagine what an
immunization yearn to dream to sort of
take the protoplasmic yearning of
biology and like articulated into this
view did and dreaming is beautiful as
long as just like with the psychedelic
trip as long as that dream is is then
integrated back into reality rather than
engineered as a way to get out of
reality yeah well it's okay definitely
and and one of the things we talk about
is the comparison between this is just a
digital future and bringing it back to
the human spectrum of experience so I'm
really interested in experience design
and I'm interested in technologically
media
experience right so this is something
I'm obsessed with just because for my
own interest in like in like being
blissed-out you know when I watch movies
when I listen to beautiful music when I
experience aesthetic arrest these are
all technologies right you know cinema
truth 24 is like the cave paintings and
all we've been experimenting with from
the beginning is is kind of challenging
our proprioception challenging where
does my body end and the rest of reality
begin I mean the museum's if you look at
the history of museums you see dioramas
what were they whoa and then Holograms
whoa you know doctor says you know a
writer wants to fit the world into a
sentence you know a filmmaker wants to
fit the world into that film you know
when you go to a museum you want to fit
history into an experience that it that
fits into your now it's almost up you
want to process the world into this
moment you know see the world in a grain
of sand right well so Diana Slattery has
that amazing article about she talked
about the term the trope hi
and she says whether it's drug-induced
highs or technological highs high
resolution high fidelity our desire to
just chase these blissful mind-body
states that seems to be integral to the
human condition and that's using our
tools and folding those tools back into
the cell to essentially hack perception
hacked experience hack consciousness I
mean don't you think that's an amazing
opportunity for us to play I mean does
that excite you an amazing opportunity
for us to play for sure and although
I've seen you know many acid casualties
along the way of the people that chased
just a few too many highs I'd hate I'd
hate for our civilization to become an
acid casualty but the other problem for
me is who's building these technologies
who are we in concert with you know when
I say okay so Google is building these
technologies and yeah they're also
building robots that really are good at
chasing and shooting down people and
well they're donating it to the World
Wildlife Federation to chase poachers
who we all know are really bad so that's
a very socially acceptable way to build
robot drones that chase down people but
and we know Google will do no evil so we
don't have to worry about that and the
government would never get a hold of the
I mean I don't know it's just it's while
we're chasing our highs we are
supporting the creation of a
technological
structure that we're not really in
charge of so what does that scare you I
mean do you anticipate like some
totalitarian information state where
we're not free or or McKenna talking
about us each moving into universes of
our own construction where big data is
used to create engineered Serendipity's
or everything that's always around is
custom for us and our tastes and the
smart systems that start do we dovetail
our minds to our tools but when the
tools start dovetailing back the
distinction between self and world is
going to become really flimsy because
everything is gonna have mind in it
everything is gonna have my mind in it
because everything is gonna be
responding to my tastes and my desires
and my needs I mean I imagine I sort of
playground I kind of wake walking lucid
dream mediated by technology kind of
like the end of Anila sky and he's in
that lucid dream could be that's what I
fantasize would be it could be but you
know for me the best part of a trip is
always waking up in the morning I mean
coming down is the good part you know it
should be anyway coming down is the part
where you're like okay you know what
yeah what did I learn and how do I apply
this and what is this and then you know
and then you go out in the woods and you
you smell reality again from that new
from that new place and you realize oh
my god I've only tip I'm only 1% of what
I could be and I think we both shared
that we're only 1% of what we could be
the question is where is that other 99%
is that other 99% by building these
technologies that can then do this stuff
or are we leaving that 99 percent behind
and building technologies that can house
the 1% that we already know about you
just said something that that I want
that really got me excited you talked
about what happens after the trip this
idea that ego death results in a kind of
reset of the self and you should go and
smell the rose mell reality and you've
been changed in some way you've been
conditioned by the experience and you
want to go out and be a better person
and you want to exercise new
possibilities right and so forth so I
want to ask you and and that's in the
today and to the very best thing about
psychedelics is you come back and you
see the structures that you've been
accepting at face value
as given circumstances of your reality
and you see them as social constructions
of people who may or may not have had
our best our best interests at heart
right so when we we when our very best
digital people are say building Twitter
and and and disrupting this industry or
that but then what do they do they go to
Daddy at Goldman Sachs and do an IPO and
reify the worst of our society they
basically turn it into another prop for
Wall Street the opportunity of moving
into a digital age is not to build up
not to build upon the mistakes of the
Industrial Age but to challenge the
Industrial Age and retrieve all of the
values that got repressed the last time
that's McKenna's archaic revival that's
McLuhan's retrieval of values so what
what I did what I saw on my
technological trip when I saw it was oh
my gosh you mean we can transact and
appear to appear fashion without
corporations oh we can invent local
currencies and and we can use our
iPhones to do authentication we can we
can look back at reality again rather
than just build on the the artificial
structures that we've had before
and my concern is when we just go
headlong for the hi there's a ton of
powers-that-be
that are more than happy to serve you
that huh yeah to get you and me hi as
long as they get the big data that they
need in order to predict our you know or
influence our upcoming behavior so it's
revolution or hedonism yeah well you
know it's interesting though but
sometimes I feel like okay so when I
watch a movie I'm a consumer who's
paying money feeding an existing system
a business that is a thriving business a
corporate business that is you know
those that criticize films say that it's
you know making it's like a soma that's
keeping us all Placid and mindlessly
entertained but when I see a movie that
I love I don't necessarily want to have
a revolution against that system I
actually enjoy the film and I'm glad I
live in a world where these expert
filmmakers can amass these resources to
make these amazing cultural technologies
for me to experience
I don't know those they're still they're
still great movies we were talking when
you go to a Chris Nolan movie and it'll
blow your little mind I mean that's
that's a good thing not a bad thing yeah
but I guess that's what I'm saying is
when you it's when we're not conscious
so they're just like okay now I can make
my own movies right and you're one of
the lucky ones right you can buy a Sony
camera and buy an Apple computer and buy
some Time Warner roadrunner uplink speed
and you can now instead of paying to
watch a movie you can pay to make a
movie and upload it to YouTube where
Google will own it and if you're one out
of three million you can be one of the
few that becomes I mean well the U or
Google will own it etc etc but the point
is technology has lowered the barriers
of entering a new town it has been a
flooding a new town but the the number
of people that have actually made it in
the DIY system if you look at music or
filmmaking is less than made it in the
old system the the disparity between
indistinct are why do you mean is why
because I think it's actually because
they're not really selling the music
because what we're really selling in
this system are our networks you know
and that's what I was just talking to
Oliver Luckett who runs the audience so
you know he's kind of it's a social
media agency for rock stars and pop
stars and what they realized is if
you're going to be a pop star you're not
going to make money selling your records
what you can make money doing is selling
your Twitter followers is selling your
Facebook Likes so what is hopefully what
a romantic currency of attention right
right attention resource there's an
infinite amount of signals competing for
our attention we're all suffering from
bandwidth anxiety right those weak
louder like that yeah but those with the
loudest microphone or amplifier in the
age of information that's where the
wealth is right you can get role
attention you can control the world it's
interesting because in the book the
mating mind the guy talks about how the
human capacity for creativity you know
language art poetry is really just the
human version of the peacock feather and
that we went from trading in jeans to
trading in memes huh so today
evolutionary success is really those
that are controlling the Twitter
followers right I mean people like maybe
more memes the widest and far that's it
and it was little little schlemiel like
me who liked the trading with memes
thing better than the trading with James
thing that's why I couldn't live in Los
Angeles I had to come to New York where
you know where I can get currency with
the things I say rather than you know my
flesh yeah rather than your six-pack
yeah yeah yeah and you got both so so um
okay so I want to go back to what you
were saying before about resetting the
self coming down from the trip whatever
that trip was technologically mediated
or drug mediated and the therapeutic
aspects of these experiences because one
of the things that I've been obsessing
with lately and I've doing videos about
it is the subject of awe and I tell
people that
ah is ie it's a sort of an antidote to
existential despair you know that I'm
really into Ernest Becker
he says the human condition is defined
by the fact that we know that we are
mortal beings so we lose sleep over the
fact that one day in the future we're
going to die and that imbues the human
experience with the kind of absurdity
right we are simultaneously gods and
worms we can ponder the infinite yet you
know we watch those that we love get old
ourselves get old and eventually die and
so I find that whether it's psychedelic
therapy or whatever inspiration aw
aesthetic arrests are the antidotes to
that experience so ego death being
blissed-out arrests time temporarily
pushes aside thoughts of impending doom
yeah takes us off that people mover
that's carrying everyone else towards
death and then there was a study that
came out of Stanford where they
basically expose people to experiences
of awe which they defined as experiences
of such perceptual expansion the peoples
had to upgrade their mental schema de to
accommodate the experience and what they
found is that people who have regular
incidences of awe are left with
increased altruism increased well-being
increased feelings of compassion towards
other people etc etcetera like there's
all these oh yeah equal ways after
blowing your own mind yeah therapeutic
there are and awe
was systematically extracted from the
human experience over the last 600 years
as people in awe people who have all
experiences they're dangerous were
unpredictable they get hit by a car
because we chase why we have which is
why we have psychedelic medicine right
but psychedelic drugs there's still
drugs right there for people who are
sick there for society that's lost the
ability to encounter or right and they
reacquaint us with all not so that we
have to do it again and again and again
as as Alan Watts said once you get the
message hang up the phone yeah but
rather to be able to experience aw as I
am right now just sitting with you or
looking at my daughter we're having sex
or looking at a sunset like ah all right
the all is everywhere I need that
medicine now the technology is also good
because you can't get everybody high on
acid we found out the 60s people are
afraid you know but the computer great
all right so let's give people some
experience yes oh it smells great not so
that they can then travel into the
computer into the land of all right but
so that now that they recognize ah or a
simulation of awe in this case they can
come back to the real world and go oh my
gosh but it's true but the
existentialist philosophers were always
saying it I mean chem who used to say
life should be lived to the point of
Tears I mean you read the romantic law
it should be lived to the point of Tears
yeah we should go to a movie to
experience a simulation of someone
else's life
you can go we can have it in our own
lives that's a tragedy but you know the
problem is that an have it in our own
lives there's a thing it's here it's
available we don't need to pay Google
for the aw yeah but we don't this is a
way for what I don't know I still I feel
I want to hate you a playlist with the
custom music that I picked to be playing
conditioning my real experience so I
still want to use the technology but
there's borrow from this reality out
there you can listen to to like just the
trees rustling yeah the trees rustling
the the I mean gosh going to my favorite
thing and I lived in the West Village
back when that was affordable was there
was a public school there and I would
stand that the the chain-link fence when
they had recess and listened in perfect
stereo to all the kids playing in this
thing and that was aw yeah right but it
was all was right it was right there
I've always envied people that just are
naturally in awe my mother is one of
those people I mean she's
one of those people that says everything
moves there every she finds beauty
almost in everything and then some of us
that have to find ways to mediate and
induce an occasion that experience right
and so yeah it's just something I'm
really yeah this is your stuff now your
stuff your I mean well the videos are
medicine in that simple because people
your hard work you're doing this you
cared about your stocks and does it go
up or down and then my private skull of
my kid and now I can watch a
three-minute video and go oh and
that's the point people to play with
their brain play with your brain yeah
it's here for that yeah but history the
reason I did those videos was yes thank
you for using the term medicine because
I did them as self medication like it
was like you know if I was in any kind
of stupor if I was afflicted by the
banality of the everyday the bin there's
and done that so the adult mind as
Michael Pollan writes I needed to be
reset and not every month does
Christopher Nolan really have films you
got to wait for them you know so when
there's no when there's nothing I can
purchase to give me that experience I
want to go and make that experience and
finally I have the tools right and so I
have limited resources and perhaps a
kind of a limited attention span and as
kind of impatience and a desire to just
make it now so rather than spending six
months doing you a feature doc I was
like I want to make these three minute
videos because I want to make it I want
to take it three minute hit like might
hit a DMT like it's just like three
minute but I wanted to have all the
energy of the most amazing movie trailer
you've ever seen and all the ideas
packed in there densely and I want it to
be like an inception like you watch it
and then it goes to percolates and it
stays with you and this is that and yeah
I mean it's for me it's it's yeah it's
been medicine ya know and it's cool the
trick though is to help people
understand that you're not necessarily
describing reality but you're giving
metaphorical oh yeah ways of
understanding about so the mind is like
a processor you know where the we are
like computers we are uploading stuff we
are memes are like genes and we are
infecting one another with ideas
those metaphors they they help me
understand the world a lot more it makes
everything makes sense that's the thing
no it does they're just prone right in
in our society those metaphors are prone
to the sort of Margaret Mead Gregory
Bateson abstracted understanding of
reality as this this kind of
participatory mediated spectacle okay so
let's talk about cultural operating
systems and the consensus trance you
were talking about that before that when
people have these psychedelic
experiences that come out of it and they
realize that these social rigid
frameworks that seems so solid and so
real are and much more fluid than we
think they are they've been created by
other people what do you think is the
same thing that happens when you watch a
Shakespeare play or a breakfast or have
good sex or go to a good religious
ritual - yeah yeah I mean but well so
what do you think how can we upgrade our
social operating systems like do you
ever speculate of what a better society
yeah I mean for me we all run around
naked for me the digital thing is is is
so key because we have migrated you know
from an industrial age society to a
digital one but for me the digital is
the opposite of the kind of global
Google meta Network thing for me digital
was always the digits right it was about
return these are the digits that's what
digital means the return to the fingers
to to to not to individuality as
individual consumers but to you know the
local means of production and you know
for for me though the whole local thing
the the Etsy thing the retrieval of
medieval values and Burning Man and are
and occupy are all about the same thing
I mean I love occupy not in the terms of
a political occupation but the idea of
occupying reality you know that's right
let's only pawn this space right here
does that I mean because I was a kid who
went from the television mass media
experience to the digital experience
which was so peer-to-peer and connected
well so that was either hear you talking
about like occupy
this be here now I haven't been to
Burning Man I'm embarrassed to say but I
need to make it to make it over there I
read Eric Davis's as they on Burning Man
and you've been there oh my god but you
know one of them now it's a it's not
burning then any more than the
Internet's the Internet I mean there's
no you know if you're young Google
executive you go and prove you're cool
by well the people that have transcended
experience is there to me it seems like
the place creates this kind of radical
novelty that by virtue of just being
bombarded by the juxtaposition of so
much originality it's so different than
what you see every day you don't have
mental references for what you're seeing
so it induces that that wonder that the
imagination explosion and what that does
is it serves the bits like a drug right
it serves the purpose of the
transforming your perception of the
present moment and the passing of time
the unfolding of time and just
experience changes right subjectivity is
transformed right to the point respects
to the Hatters of subjectivity it's like
but to the purpose of then being able to
recognize and foster the things that you
see in real life I mean I was at a
tree-trimming party with a pinata the
other day and the pinata fell and all
the boys are shoving and kicking and
trying to gather everybody gets their
candy and their little toys and all that
and we're all like oh my god this is oh
so and then you know like ten minutes
later nobody's looking because then the
kids are off I see like you know five
girls in a circle and my daughter is one
of them these are eight-year-old girls
in a circle and they're trading like
candy with each other and it's this this
very sophisticated sort of modalities of
what different things are worth is a
piece of plastic it's a like a toy and
that's what to me and there and so
immediately a peer-to-peer
a bazaar in the medieval sense a bazaar
assembled it was social it was
commercial it was it was every day and I
was just like it happens it does happen
I mean in this natural club that was
Burning Man happened there you know
without without the drugs and without
the computers right right so
okay I want to ask you about creativity
just like big word use a creative one
well we're both authorized no no but
just how do you just randomly just
define creativity moments of a ha what
happens when human beings step out of
their usual mental frameworks what
happens what happens in the brain what
results from a creativity is in most the
the fun way to describe what creativity
is no one has a great definition for it
especially in a market society but
creativity is when humans do what the
only humans can do you know creativity
is and is the expression of the paradox
you know the ambiguity the queerness the
weirdness yeah it's just creates these
unique novel yeah possibility yes well
it's interesting cuz I've been thinking
a lot about you just said that ambiguity
and this and that the word liminality
has to do with like the in between and
I'm really I've become really interested
in these immersive site-specific
interactive theatre experiences I was
talking about punch-drunk yeah yeah no
more there's another one in Brooklyn
called then she fell which is a
reference to Alice tumbling down the
rabbit hole and in these theater
experiences they create this space where
you can pretty much go anywhere you want
and it's this nonlinear interactive
experience of the narrative so you had
you don't experience it in order and you
kind of are connecting the dots as you
experience it and figuring out what's
going on is kind of the purpose of what
you're supposed yeah but you enter it
kind of describe the experiences being
inside of someone else's dream and so it
is this liminal space between dreams and
reality kind of like when you're
watching a movie kind of like when
you're watching a piece of theater
time-space they kind of collapsed you
can crisscross you know and cross cut to
anywhere experiencing anything and you
believe it so that's the landscape of
mind in the landscape of imagination do
you think we'll ever be able to create
virtual reality technologies that allow
us to essentially live in that space all
the time to live in like landscapes of
mind to just completely leave behind the
the sort of gravity of the body and its
and its
rigid have to feed it and have to go to
sleep at this time you know just live in
this Wonderland all the time my sense is
if we do it it will be that the price
will be we leave behind a few billion of
our fellows to be in non mediated
wonderful virtual things I mean it's the
great way to get the city on the cloud
you know so we can all be in virtual
reality as long as we have you know
little brown people and subcontinent's
you know feeding the the coal into the
well whatever and to the sumimasen have
like nanotech or solar technologies they
could make this perfectly yeah it is it
is and because I don't think that we
would have the drive to inhabit an
alternative reality unless there was
something we were trying to get away
from you know be it's um you know
Phillip K Dickie and apocalyptic dry
desert future and it's like oh well
I'm going into second life see you later
honey
you know so you okay so you always think
that the appeal is that this is bad and
that is good rather than you know this
is pretty good humanity's come to this
certain point but now there's this like
mental universe we can go to that's
infinite and boundless I mean that was
the dream of cyberspace
right there's corridors of the mind yeah
I think Gibson I think it the more the
better the virtual realities we build
the better I would think people will get
at distinguishing between the virtual
and the real you know the Kevin Kelly
says real is going to be a really
relative term in the future yeah but
Kevin or Kelly is is a person who is as
a certain kind of Christian is imagines
the end of the world I mean they're
they're they're people that are still
stuck in what I would consider to be a
Renaissance era linear arc of sort of
beginnings middles and ends they're not
playing the infinite game where the
object of the game is to keep the game
going they're still playing a
Renaissance era game where the object of
the game is to win the game they where
they're stuck in in the culture of the
book which on I write books I love them
but books are about beginnings middles
and ends
whereas games video games
booklet number and going can't can't do
it
luckily but but but no I mean it's it's
when Kevin Kelly talks about the
Technium when he describes technology as
the seventh kingdom of life and he says
that it's a living thing subject to
evolutionary forces that has wants and
needs do you think that this is just
crap or do you think that there's a
truth to what he's saying or I think it
is like a living thing I think it's it's
but it's it's algorithmic in nature you
know it's it's a program and while
people are very algorithmic ideology of
programs it's like a program and there's
many things that are programmatic about
it but the more you hone in on that
program it skirts away from you like a
tomato seed under your finger and you
realize oh it's not the DNA it's the
proteins around the DNA well of course
well now we know it oh it's the food oh
it's not the proteins it's like
something else and you know there's a
lot of complexity for sure yes it's not
just complexity though it's not you know
I'm not in the end I'm not a materialist
you know I don't I think that there's
something going on here that we don't
yet know about you know I guess that's
content or something that that we barely
we barely even perceive reality much
less are we able we can't even recreate
a simulation of what we perceive much
less the 99.9% of reality that we don't
perceive so I don't want to talk about
the limitations in understanding our own
consciousness not to mention our
limitations in creating instruments to
pursue world because and we can't see
the very small but we create a
microscope we can see the very large but
we create a telescope I mean we really
can we appear into like the universe
yeah pretty vividly yeah exactly saying
what you're saying these guys buy a
model big buy a model of reality and it
may be true where you know there was
this matter you know it was a boom and
then all things banged into each other
and they got more complex and they got
so complex and eventually there was a
merchant consciousness from it right
that there was the Big Bang and then
there was time well what if they're
wrong right because they still don't
know you think that no what are
satisfying answer what if consciousness
preceded the Big Bang what if
consciousness was a prerequisite for the
Big Bang rather than the result of the
Big Bang
you know then if it was then we'll wait
a minute now what are we playing with no
so if we don't understand sort of the
very basic building blocks of reality
I'm concerned about of ditching reality
for another one I love Playland
I love Disneyland I love movies I love
all these things but I would never
mistake them for reality Disneyland's a
great idea I mean and if you know a
world where the trains worked on time I
feel like Disneyland is what would have
happened if the Nazis had won and
weren't evil you know God you know and
that's fine then that's fine but it's
not the world right but let me ask you
something there you talked about how
okay you like movies you like videogames
you like that but they're not reality
you know one of the interesting ideas in
Chris Nolan's film Inception is this
notion that the dream is real when
you're in it so if the simulation if the
representation can become immersive
enough can you ever essentially trick
hack or convince your brain to forget to
remember that it's subject subjecting
yourself to a simulation yes for example
when I went to see gravity on IMAX in 3d
which I thought was a technical
achievement in film I'd never seen
before in terms of the places where the
camera could go it just didn't it didn't
make sense
you couldn't place it and it was so
immersive that during certain sequences
my body would jolt with the movements
on-screen as if it was happening to me
it was going primordial deeper than my
ability to remember this is a movie and
I think that eventually more and more of
our simulated experiences are going to
be like that so it won't matter if
they're not real when they're done
because when you're in them they'll
become real it'll the dream will be real
while you're in it what do you think of
that it's a cool idea right yeah I'm
just trying to convince you to like this
I like it I just don't like it more than
what I got you know I like it sure it's
great it's great cool go for it
wonderful but if we are gonna build
these things let's go back and say okay
what's the purpose of these things the
purpose could be just cuz I want to get
high right just like the kid taking acid
in that ac/dc parking lot instead of in
the dorm room you know trying to figure
out the world so you're gonna do it you
need the purpose is the farces yeah I
think that well we're talking about like
psychedelic therapies but it feels like
human beings we have we need to have
regular experiences that are cathartic
we use like ego death rebirth
simulations right like even I was
talking about Alan Harrington who wrote
the book the immortal list that even our
lovers even when we're in love our
lovers act as stand-ins for various
dream figures in a staged managed
resurrection where the pilgrim without
faith can die and live again and we want
to just do it is really you need these
archetype spaces these landscapes of
mind where we sort out you know
like that's the world the world of the
self the world inside and that's what
these movies connect to I think they do
they do and that's fine it's just you
know the world of the self can be
ultimately a lonely place it's not it's
not a social place you know the world is
you work on yourself sure you know and
maybe this is New York everyone goes to
therapy for 45 minutes once a week or
twice I mean we all know what that what
inner work is about and why it's great
but the reason we do in our work is so
that we go out of the office and then
engage with people and deal with the
real problems of distributing the
surplus of stuff that we have in America
somehow to all the people that need it
instead of burning food every week and
ripping down houses and coloring on you
because the prices aren't high enough
it's like the the practical concerns are
are so real yeah well I completely agree
with you but the practical concerns are
also they are being addressed I mean you
know there was an article in The New
York Times recently that said that the
the lowest level of poverty the most
extreme form of poverty has almost been
eliminated across the world you have you
know Steven Pinker wrote the better
angels of our nature and his Ted
the myth of violence it says that
contrary to what you see on the news the
chances of a man dying at the hands of
another man are the lowest than they've
ever been in history you know I mean
there's all these indicators that you
know things are getting better but you
know the media feeds us doom and gloom
so I mean obviously everything you're
saying is true but like it's not like
there's not an active effort right now
at addressing the fundamental challenges
of humanity I mean do you have optimism
at all in that space oh I've got lots of
optimism I just want to make sure we're
you don't use these medicines the same
way that say America uses prozac which
is a way they're enough to to to numb to
numb yeah exactly to to to help us cope
with reality as it is rather than engage
reality to make it less painful and on
that note I think it's time for a Q&A
it's about 9 o'clock you don't assume
that this is like a pro ante here yeah
we're both Pro and anti and all that
we're kind of I mean it's sort of the
the rules of brain jazz in a way you
kind of stake out positions on another
night under different medications we
could easily be taking opposite yes
opposite stands it's just sort of where
I'm at right now because I just really
disappointed really at all for me it's
done my disappointment in Bitcoin you
know if I read the article about
yesterday it really is I'm disappointed
it's like we have that we have the
opportunity to invent entirely new
currencies rather than just remake an
investor's speculative central currency
in a digital format it's like so stupid
mic-check
hi you guys taught at different points
about the brain gem about these value
shifts I think you talked about how in
the Industrial Age yeah you know we got
stripped of some pre-existing values and
we got some new ones and I've heard
other people refer to the digital age as
also a knowledge age you know so some of
the valleys are already kind of like
embedded in what you're saying so like
the peer-to-peer kind of like network
that's that's obviously kind of like a
value that rises up
post-industrial age whatever and now
what other looking into like let's say
2050 right where you do have this kind
of like radical transformation radical
kind of integration of organic matter
and artificial of solar technology all
this stuff just like it's at a mature
stage I wouldn't say it's stabilized but
it's definitely like at a mature stage
what are the values that humanity will
hold kind of like and prioritize in the
future who knows you're gonna be here I
mean I think right now that's part of
why this moments so interesting is it's
up for grabs you know right now we're
choosing whether we're going or reify
the values of the Industrial Age which
are efficiency over time extracting
value out of people and resources and
all that in order to push through some
how do the Industrial Age on steroids or
are we going to use this opportunity to
do some cultural resetting and retrieve
the values that were repressed the last
time out which is when the Renaissance
happened and when the Renaissance
happened we got you know the invention
of the individual and centralization and
perspective we got you know a whole lot
of values and other ones were oppressed
like women women and and peer-to-peer
local the bazaar all those kinds of
things I would love to say in 2050 we
end up in a reality where eighty
eighty-five percent of our needs are met
locally through peer-to-peer networks of
people were engaged with in the places
that we live and ten or fifteen percent
of our weird cool stuff comes from big
international high tech companies that
make us bones that have very very big
supply chains you know that will move
into either a some kind of a you know a
world with many cottage industries that
are all networked and in order to be you
know vastly more efficient or if the big
data people have their way we'll end up
entirely more predictable than
then we've been before and we'll be
easily influenced to just purchase
whatever I'm the next thing is you know
there was a recent article that said
that physicists discovered a basically a
law of physics that can physics that can
predict the growth of cities so like
even the behavior of human beings and
the unpredictable changes that happen
that it can all be described by an
equation you know that cities are like
organisms and they have all these
metabolic rates so who knows I mean
maybe what big data is gonna reveal is
something that it scares us to admit
which is that we're not really these
free autonomous creative beings even
though it feels that way subjectively
but an a macro scale and looking at all
the data points that we're just
algorithmic Cascades after all and we
have to maybe live with that duality
like sure the big data AIS can predict
everything we're gonna want but it
doesn't feel that way to me
for us it'll feel like we live in this
like carnival and novelty where
everything is interesting and everything
is awesome and people in the imagination
business in 2050 have storytelling
technologies that are dazzling in their
capacity to wow us and the movies like
gravity you know in to 2050 will be that
much cooler and the materialists you
know dismiss this sensibility they call
it essentialism oh it's essentialism
you're a Sophists you know it's some
weird romantic you know melancholy for
this idea that human beings are are
weird and that your perception matters
so that you have free will and on this
illusion is good enough for me to I'm
gonna work with it you know I'm gonna
act as if I'm gonna do babe as if this
is real and as if they are the ones who
haven't figured things out you know and
and at the very least there's to be a
balance between materialism and whatever
we want to call this spirituality for
lack of a better word you know rather
than I'm having to fall all the way into
one camp or another you know and
throughout history they've generally
moved hand-in-hand and it was really
only after the invention of you sort of
rational science and that that this
stuff that we're talking about got poo
pooed as being some kind of whoo weird
you know womanly you know for tough
copper a woolly master nonsense where I
think it's it's it's real it's as real
as your
option of reality and your perception of
reality is is more I would agree as all
we really have to go on more than what
we then the metaphors we have to
describe it thank you
hey guys Hey quick question where are
you yeah okay so do you think drugs in
psychedelics are still gonna be around
the age of singularity or fifty or
hundred years from now like how are
people gonna get high is there going to
be in the form of a hack or computer
code or how are they gonna open up those
doors of perception well this is the
thing is also even the way that people
describe drugs in most cases is not as
interesting to me as some people I don't
know if you've talked about this but
this guy rich Doyle who I really enjoy
as well
he says that drugs are actually
information technologies and you know
the philosopher le ADA calls them
technologies of ecstasy and he talks
about humanity's cognitive toolkit you
know as essentially stuff that you know
we found in nature but we've been using
it as part of our mental toolkit for
tens of thousands of years so I imagine
we're gonna have a new generation of
smart drugs because just because it's
chemistry doesn't mean it's not
technology you know these are still
gonna be tools that we use to play with
the essence of self and I think that the
best is yet to come
I mean people read a book like brave new
world and they're like oh there's so
much I don't know I mean there's a
there's a guy called David Pierce he
wrote the hedonistic imperative on the
internet it's a wonderful treatise about
how we're gonna use nano tech and
biotech to create dazzling new spectrums
of subjectivity like realms of mind that
are unfathomable as in fathomable to us
as the nuances of shakespeare are to a
great ape and so it's useless to even
speculate in a way yeah and you know if
we get if we get really really good at
fine-tuning our shamanic alchemy right
and when we can play the brain exactly
as we want it you know cool
but there's something that the mushrooms
tell you that that synthetic perfectly
modulated chemical won't the mushrooms
are going to tell you some stuff you may
not want to really hear when you're high
like it you're up the planet
Eire hey you're cheating on your
girlfriend there why haven't you talked
to me in the last three years I have
something just I mean it's like you're
not a guilt-free high it's not it's not
much guilt I mean yeah I mean it's not
it has the the plants the sacred plants
have agendas
we're in relationship with ayahuasca
we're in relationship with the Torah you
know and were the ones that we make
we're not in relationship with then
we're just going so again it's about I
think it's a bit about balance you know
Rupert Sheldrake talked about there's
all a morphic genetic field of our whole
met with species memory with the plant
maybe but I think it's the plant you
know I think it is the the the plants
that we've been in relationship with for
however many millennia you know
understand and they can help balance us
in ways that we might not choose to
balance ourselves with well you know if
we moved exclusively toward designer
designer chemicals and designer states
of consciousness hey guys I just want to
say thank you for just blowing our mind
and that was way too fast but bear with
me while I wait worked this question so
first and foremost you know in a society
we're the only socially conditioned and
accepted plane of consciousness is kind
of that producer-consumer plane of
consciousness where the only way that we
can afford ourself the opportunity to
explore the world of art and spirit is
exactly to do so is to afford to do that
and and create a company where maybe we
can unfurl through our creative mind in
that company but of course a company or
a business is there to create financial
security to create money I just want to
know how could we afford the opportunity
to stay in this world the world of art
and spirit and mind the soul but what
I'm really interested in is
what was your answer to this question
before you were Douglas rushkoff media
theorist and author or Jason Silva
futurist economists and philosopher how
did you live in to this answer and how
has that changed now that you're on the
other side I mean I was lucky right I
for the first you know eight or ten
years of my career I made eight to ten
thousand dollars a year you know and I
just didn't mind because I was having
fun while the yuppie scum were all going
to work you know so you mean that was
the beauty of coming out as a slacker
because it was it was you know I mean it
was celebrated that with me and my
friends the idea was not was not to have
to work that's why now when I look at
Obama talking about jobs it's great jobs
for everybody it's like who wants a
job I don't want a job I want
stuff and access and all that and I'd
like to create you know things and and
have meaningful engagement but I don't
want a job you know job as an artifact
of the Renaissance people didn't have
jobs until 1300 they used to make stuff
and trade you know they only got jobs
when it was illegal to mixed up yourself
you had to go work for a chartered
corporation so you know when I hear
questions like that it's like oh because
we're accepting the premise of this bs
Industrial Age business model that was
there for kings and and and and and
booze wahoo with long since left the
building and we don't even remember it's
their operating system that we're
keeping going I'm so there's that
lentils and rice is another lentils and
yeah but you can you can live a long
time on lentils rice and water you can
and find spices and stuff you know you
can you know without even being freegan
you can survive and I did that for for a
good long time and I tutored kids on
their SATs I mean that was taught me a
lot because I was in Beverly Hills I
would drive to these Beverly Hills
mansions in my used Ford you know escort
and I'd parked like between the gardener
and the maid
and then go tutor some super rich kid
you know for three hours for 35 bucks an
hour or something which is enough to
live a week you know if you if you did
it frugally so no it was it was um maybe
I was worried Zhi er times than now on
some level but now I was I was lucky in
frankly the fact that I was you know
shoved out the chute of an Ivy League
education after a you know Westchester
High School childhood I mean you could
float you can you so you've got such an
advantage already it's like it's not
being you're not being put out on the
ground you're being you know at that
level of wealth you know the
upper-middle class parent you're being
shot out you got a long way to go down
before so I'm a child of privilege you
know I see I see it that way that my
like the fellows at Princeton who are
all these private school rich kids saw
me as the poor kid was the funny thing
you know but you know so it was it was
luck and and not getting off the bus you
know the I think the big thing is you
know I've never worked for some other
things so everything I did was investing
in my own I hate to use the word like
brand but in my own franchise in me you
know and so it builds you know the
freelance lifestyle is more secure than
having a real job because they can't
fire you and you lose this contract you
got five more I mean it's it's well it's
one of you say that because I mean
there's some school of thought that says
that in the future everything is gonna
be essentially freelance and people talk
about the rise of the creative class and
these people empowered by technologies
and the the some article I read that was
unbelievable it was saying that there's
a sort of mentality of people living in
places like Berlin or Williamsburg
Brooklyn that think it abominable to
have to work for somebody else and these
are like these creative people that have
the the education of the upper class but
maybe the income of like the lower
middle class and so they're like these
super intellectually affluent people
that don't necessarily need things so
they're not as dependent on money
because they don't need to buy as much
stuff because they have everything just
their laptop on their iPhone that's it
you know so that's really interesting
but um to answer your question I mean I
think for me I like
Stephen Johnson has a great line it says
the world is full of clues and you can
read your way through it so I've always
kind of felt that like the signs are
there you know connecting the dots and
how I can do my thing and make it work
you know I was lucky enough to grow up
in a household where my parents like
encouraged me to kind of find my bliss
you know and just make it happen but
also I think there's little techniques
George Carlin actually was interviewed
recently about his career and he was
talking about psycho cybernetics and he
discovered this book on psycho
cybernetics are you familiar with this
and he was saying that you know the
brain is essentially a goal seeking
mechanism and that there's these devices
these tricks you can use to create
impressions in your brain that then
teach your brain what to look for in the
world to connect the dots to achieve
your goals so he says the first
impression is okay you get an idea or
you notice something that inspires you
and you're like all that that's what I
want to do or that's kind of that's what
moves me so that's impression one
impression too is you write it down so
you write it down you're already making
a second impression you're acknowledging
that you're writing it down impression
three is looking at your notes later and
then by that point you've kind of primed
your brain with this to this trajectory
of this this network of ideas or
concepts or whatever things that are
turning you on and then what happens is
you know a few days later you're walking
down the street and all of a sudden you
start noticing all these serendipitous
signs that are connected to like what
you were thinking about and people are
always call that magical thinking
they're like oh it's the secret I'm
attracting it it's not that is that
you've primed your brain to connect the
dots using that meta pattern right
you've because the signs are always
there you know you can read anything in
any way but in a way you're kind of like
hacking your brain to pay attention to
the clues that are gonna help you
achieve what you want to achieve you
know I feel like I didn't know about
psycho cybernetics but it actually
echoes a lot of things I've done like if
I look at like my notes from like three
or four years ago I have like little
these scribblings and these lists of
like describing exactly what like ended
up happening in my life you know like
exactly like where I was gonna be and
what I was gonna do in describing it
it's just crazy how then you end up like
having those patterns just marked in
your head and you kind of
what is it um Wow what a question
so in from I've been reading a lot of
history recently and it seems to me that
in the large scale all of human
history's kind of like humanity trying
to get up on its knees and reach up for
this higher ideal and falling again and
then reaching up again and then falling
again and care guard said that the good
is slow the evolution of good is slow
because when you have revolution it
destabilizes what's already there and
that just causes more revolution whereas
when the good is slow its evolution it
doesn't leave anybody behind and that
was just a comment that was no question
but I recently read in a Russian
magazine an article that questioned
several spiritual leaders Christian
Buddhist just trippy people some
professors about their psychedelic
experiences and what that had to do with
their spiritual growth and they all
unanimously said that it had nothing to
do with their spiritual growth it did
cognitively and it did with their
experiential growth but nothing to do
with spiritual growth and in my personal
opinion I believe that the whole point
of spiritual growth so wouldn't the
intention well so they're um they're
amazing psychedelic experiences they
said really correspond to their state of
mind and what they were primed to find
in the first place so wouldn't the
intention whether of a good trip or
building up this amazing like
alternative reality world for ourselves
with the intention be a lot more
important than the actual trip or the
experience I mean for me psychedelics
seem much more much closer to
psychotherapy than spirituality and part
of that is because there's a duality
implicit in taking a drug right there's
before you take the drug and while
you're on the drug and after there's
you're getting high right so high means
and then you're low so there's this sort
of duality in it and for me you know I
got really into this idea of you know
birthing another
human species through collective
whatever it was sort of when I was back
in the rave psychedelic mode and I
thought that the ultimate spiritual you
know progression of our species will be
to achieve meta organism and then give
birth to some other thing and then yes I
had that then I get married and have a
kid and went oh that was easy
you know well hard but do you know what
I mean but that was like it's like the
real tools of evolution have been
staring me in the face all the time and
they are more subtle they are more slow
they're not these giant system-wide you
know revolutionary leaps revolutions or
what revolutions or circles that's what
they do I'm into Renaissance which is
what rebirth rebirth of old ideas in a
new context so you get a new technology
a new media environment and now we can
retrieve things and bring all those who
didn't come along with us and go oh my
gosh those Aboriginal people that we
thought were all doing nonsense they
actually have the technology that we
need in order to get incrementally and
incrementally forward I'd concur
hi hi so Douglas rushkoff touched on
this before on the fact that like the
agendas matter like the agendas that we
have matter and so I guess what I'm
trying to ask is that to Jason Silva
like when you talk about this future
where where our technologies
technologies advanced so much and like
singularity and what's gonna happen
after that like don't you ever feel
afraid that that things will advance so
quickly without necessarily like
thinking about what we want to do what
our agendas are what when we have this
future like I feel like what happens if
these things do end up in the wrong
hands what happens if we or if it's in
the right hands but we don't necessarily
know know what to do because things are
moving too fast for us sure I mean
there's a great article in the website
for the edge foundation that was saying
that when the astronauts first turned
around and took a picture of the
earth from space that changed the story
of who and what we were that picture
provided a different context and a
different way of seeing and
understanding ourselves and in turn
changed the story change the contact
change the story change reality of what
we are and that now in the face of these
emerging technologies that we are due
for a new story you know and I'm not a
scientist I tell people you know I was
hearing this filmmaker once saying I'm
in the feelings business or I'm in the
imagination business but I feel like you
know my small contribution to that is
the exploration in the media that I make
so my short videos are speculative and
they're about technology but they're
also about metaphysics and they're about
the human condition and they're about
love and they're about loss and they're
meant to provoke a conversation and a
discussion you know and I always say I
just want to see it at the table
you know what I'm saying because I agree
with you I think that we need to be
talking about these agendas and and I
you know I I want to be part of that
conversation for sure I mean that is an
ambition of mine for sure funny I
remember the first few times I was
interviewed when I did my first book
what are you doing with you I said I
just want to see you at the table
I used to say that all the time I just
want to be a part of that conversation a
part of the conversation yeah but the
thing is then you get your seat at the
table and now which is sort of where
she's going it's like well now what now
you got your seat at the table and then
you realize oh I'm not a journalist I'm
a propagandist right and that's okay
so what am i would am I and because
we're all propaganda there's no such
thing as balance journalism that was
right such a stupid idea that would be
balance it's like where do you put the
fulcrum stop pretending exam yeah so so
instead we're arguing for something
we're fighting for something we're
trying to persuade people of something
we're trying to at least get get our
mirror and mirror neurons activated by
people agreeing with us you know and
then what but then what do we want to
throw out there you know is is where you
go with it and it's funny for me it
started I used to say oh what I'm trying
to do is get people off their bad trip I
felt like I'd go in front of audiences
and everybody's oh technology and
there's no the Internet and I'm gonna
have to change but believing something
told me that that's what I was the phase
I'm in right yeah right yep get a low
off there bad trip that's my baby okay
wake
it's not gonna be so hard it's gonna be
okay everything is okay don't worry
don't worry don't worry if I'd have fun
you know and follow them down there down
there corridors so that they really
believe that you understand the terror
you know so that you can you can take
them out of there but then it's like so
then what you know then what I mean and
and you can do that because the phase
your life of life that you're in is you
still have the the exuberance to make
people feel comforted you know and and
okay and excited but then it's like okay
so and then when they're on the trip now
where who's steering the starship yeah
what do we what do we do with that and I
tell you it's a work in progress
yeah but the the ones who've been
steering the starship I don't trust them
I mean whether it's Mark Zuckerberg or
Sergey Brin on there they're at that
side or whether it's you know Ray
Kurzweil or Kevin Kelly and those guys I
don't trust them either I feel like they
are still in the story and I mean
they're still trying to figure out a
story and what story were you gonna tell
and I think it's time what stories are
for children you tell children's stories
at night so they go to sleep right and
you try to dose it with some programming
about the morals that you want them to
have when they grow up but I think we're
past stories now we're in in something
more like a game or more of an adventure
more an experiential something like the
theater experiments you were talking
about you know and that's a different
it's a different way of taking people
hey guys decide hey and kind of related
to that in this age where technology and
social media are kind of like this
limitless extension of our individual
being can it be kind of kind of
productive in that in interpersonal
communications where especially young
people there is no Delete key and there
it's kind of taking them away from
improvisational face-to-face
conversation where they're uncomfortable
interacting with people where they can't
go back and you know delete what they've
said or now there's there's this kind of
insecurity and just talking face to face
and then throw the market on top
you know in a value system where you
actually have a number of how many
friends you have as a way of judging you
have metrics for your popularity and
success it's tricky right ninety-four
percent of human communication happens
non-verbally so what happens and when
you grow up in an environment where
you're using texts to engage I mean you
end up with a kind of an induced
Asperger syndrome where you know you
don't make eye contact you're afraid to
make eye contact you don't know how to
establish rapport you don't know how to
not just stand up in front of a group of
people but to engage live with one other
person you resort to this or you want to
you know you you relate through the
selfie rather than through the self and
it's ya know and I agree I agree with
what you're saying to an extent but I
also think that that is a criticism that
is biased in favor of the communication
style that we're comfortable with and
that we're used to and this assumption
that this new one is not as good cetera
et cetera you know but it's hurts while
you know who is a friend of mine he says
look we're not going to be interacting
with each other through these
square-shaped devices I mean these are
temporary growing pains I mean these
devices are gonna be shrinking down to
the size of blood cells are gonna be in
our brains you know sending a text
message is gonna be I mean as very
different than like going down into a
screen like that we'll be able to just
send our thoughts to one another maybe
will transcend verbal communication
maybe will transcend words we'll be able
to like become each other and merge our
consciousnesses like I mean there are
all these speculative exotic things on
the horizon potentially but I think you
know to criticize it now as if it was
the end of like the way humans
communicate I'm like no it just it is
what it is and if you are not a fan of
it then make sure you practice being
present you know but I wouldn't label it
like the end of the world you know I
just it just is what it is I don't think
it's the end of the world but I think it
has to be balanced is all yeah you know
by some real-world engagement you know I
get concerned when I see kids in a
classroom with a teacher and they're all
looking at their tablets you know it's
like no when you're in the classroom
with the C's you shouldn't even be
looking at the book I mean I'm per
captain my captain they put away the
poetry book and they they engage with
each other no because that's that our
our face-to-face time is so it's so
minimal and how are we going to know
you know what the nanos should do if we
don't if we aren't experiencing the full
breaths
of what of what we already have I think
we have time for like one or two more
questions and then we have some vodka
for you guys if you're over 21 thank you
to Russian standard vodka for providing
the free vodka bar after this okay so um
you guys obviously have a lot of views
on psychedelics and stuff but what do
you think the most legitimate and I
guess the most efficient way to
reintroduce psychedelics as like a
legitimate tool it's already happening I
mean the majority of Americans now in
the latest polls support full marijuana
legalization the majority of Americans
so that's not even taboo anymore and as
that becomes more mainstream and more
legalized you're gonna start to see the
emergence of a class of citizen that is
not the stereotypical STONER with the
bong hit playing video games but what's
gonna happen when these oh my God all
these screenwriters like to get high all
these brilliant thinkers like to get
high Wow oh if not everybody uses it in
a destructive addicting way so this is a
tool for your creativity oh that's
interesting you know they've done a
recent study that looked at semantic
priming and marijuana found that
marijuana actually induces a state of
hyper priming which means it expands
your associative net it expands your
capacity to connect the dots between
seemingly disparate ideas a sign of
creativity right there or John Hopkins
University where they're doing
psilocybin mushroom studies with people
who have terminal illnesses and making
them like take you know process their
own mortality in a radically different
way I think even the government I mean
there's there is gonna be a psychedelic
Renaissance and I think we're already
seeing it a little bit right yeah I mean
I'm certainly more more I'm more
interested in that than watching Big
Pharma neutralize the insight elements
of these drugs and turn them into you
know sort of coping neurotransmitter
modulators you know which is where you
know for that's where they went with it
in 30
years you know so and luckily I mean the
the plants are still there you know
they're they're still well it's not
illegal yet I guess where I'm still out
of seeds really oh so the whole thing
with seeds and Monsanto and copyrighting
your genes and stuff that gets really
tricky too you know because if we take
that if we it's like right now it feels
to me like the Technosphere and the
marketplace are equivalent you know and
if we can somehow parse them from each
other I'm gonna like the Technosphere a
lot more because then the agenda then
it's to be like what's technology for
just to make us more human it's to
realize our full potential right rather
than what's technology for well it's to
enhance we can sell yeah but sell or or
or how we can extract data fair enough
okay one more question okay that's me
I'm the lucky lady right here alright
thank you so much for this conversation
incredibly invigorating Jason you are
like a electrifying optimists and
Douglas you're very reassuring practical
person for me shots of awe is like a
lightning bolt of inspiration and I got
super-high on it and then I was like
crash wait there are some things he's
just not talking about and Douglas
brings them into the conversation so
what would be incredibly awesome for me
in my world is like a superorganism the
way that like a flock of swallows flies
through the sky like if humanity could
take that metaphor and like you say use
technology to become more human and more
telepathic and more in touch with each
other that were like aesthetically
peacefully in harmony through this guy
that's what I want now what I see is the
barrier there is the digital divide and
education for me education is that like
exponential wormhole that could take us
to this utopic future that you talk of
and I would love to hear what your
thoughts are from a systemic perspective
on how we can improve and enhance the
system of education because I've worked
in education for a long time and I'll
tell you the statistics of facts in New
York City is 40 percent of our kids are
not graduating in four years that's more
than 500,000
students right now snapshot that are not
going to graduate in four years that's
the size of the city of Atlanta so it's
like a whole city sub city within our
city that are not gonna be literate let
alone digital literacy which is all
these amazing things you're talking
about which I'm so excited about but I I
got a loss and that's oh I'd love to
hear the conversation debate like what's
gonna get us there cuz I believe we're
gonna get there but I I feel like a
little bit more to hold on to yeah well
I mean just briefly I could I agree with
the problems that you're talking about
but I think education is due for a
massive upgrade I think the whole idea
of how we teach and how we learn and
whether it's doing more fMRI scans and
introducing like crazy psychotropics
into the classroom I mean maybe after
you're 18 no but I'm just saying like I
think that we need to get lost the jobs
lately answer the schools in New York no
no I just think I just think that we
need to not have an educational system
that is still of like the Industrial
Revolution age you know I mean I went to
a Montessori School which has a kind of
different philosophical agenda but at
the same time I think these technologies
and these tools are giving us radical
new opportunities I think there was a
Bill Clinton article in Time magazine
called a case for optimism where he says
that forget about the haves and the
have-nots because the cellphone was one
of the greatest inventions in history to
pull people out of poverty for example
and the idea of the digital divide is
actually not what we thought it was
going to be because people are wire
people are going on the internet whether
or not they're using that to watch lol
cat videos or actually learn stuff
online that's something else I'm a big
fan of Sir Ken Robinson and a lot of his
ideas about education and kind of like
not try to turn everybody into a robot
and so on and so forth but my mom also
taught for five years at the South Bronx
so I'm also privy to a broken system and
I understand how that works as well but
I just think you know throw away what's
not working
be willing to upgrade the whole thing
put everything into question if we have
to I mean start yeah round up I mean
yeah it's funny this question it brings
up everything sort of I've been thinking
about tonight I mean on the one hand the
the the thing I did after my period
after my decade of all was looked and
basically said
I'm gonna go to the darkest places of of
mind and of reality and test my awe and
I'm gonna go as deep as I can without
losing it and then pull back and figure
out how to work with it so you know the
first thing I went to South Africa
before the elections and go around
Salado and see basically test myself in
the darkest possible places to then look
what what do we do you know there's as a
way of challenging my awe and earning my
awe right by by going dark so when I go
dark I'm not a pessimist but I rather
than just talking people down off their
bad trips now from my happy young place
what I do is I go into that the only
good trip is a bad trip right I go into
the bad trip so that I can then find my
way back it gives lost as I can and the
despair of all my god and money in the
road and then come back education is
definitely one of those places and
education is the place where we can say
okay we can use digital technology to
build on our education system and make
kids more job ready and teach them code
and do this and give them that and so
they can get into IBM and they got in
other words or you know and that would
be the constructivist approach the
dialectic approach we're gonna build on
top of that or we can say digital
technology and the big digital change is
an opportunity to go back and say and
this is what the Sophists would do this
is what the the the grammarian would do
in this situation is go
what's education for what is it for
right now what it's for if you look at
you know Edward Cubberley and who wrote
who created a modern American or New
York education system it was to create
we all know you know workers for
American factories right so that's why
they have bells after every class this
is why your schools like that they're
trying to make you a good factory person
the teacher is the foreman and you
students are the workers and the bell
rings you go to the next place you learn
you memorize this you do that follow my
orders and go you have a Hall Pass no
good but that's what it's for it was
constructive to do that and now what is
education for you know edgy and it
depends it depends on what we think the
future of the economy is I mean if the
if education is to create a new
peer-to-peer Society of of creative
people who were
engaging if we've accept the fact that
we only need people working ten percent
of the time in order to give everyone
that food and shelter and stuff they
need what are we doing with the other
ninety percent of human activity so then
what you have to do is go back and you
say oh well education is to imbue people
with the ability to do critical thinking
you know it's it's - it's it's the the
need for the liberal arts education is
actually more important now than it was
before because now we need a generation
who's going to ask the big questions if
anything the purpose of Education now is
to create the people who can develop the
next education system there you go you
know it's very own net on it but yeah
well thank you guys join us for a drink
yeah